hello and welcome to the shiki science
show where in this video i'm going to
tell you about
the integrated stress response and a
molecule
known as isrib that inhibits this
integrative stress response
and how this compound has been shown in
a variety of studies
to be able to allow mice to form better
long-term memories
hence acting as a cognitive enhancer so
in this video we'll take a look at this
data
and evaluate this strategy and look at
not just what
but how it's actually acting to be able
to enhance long-term memory in mice
but before we get on to that we need to
have a good understanding of the
integrated
stress response which i promise is a
really interesting
biochemical signaling pathway now i had
an entire lecture about the integrated
stress response
during my undergrad and i'm gonna try
and summarize it in just a few minutes
to brace yourselves and i have put some
links to some pretty good review
articles if you're interested in the
topic
and want to learn a bit more about it i
do recommend you checking it out
but anyway effectively the integrated
stress response
is an evolutionary conserved signaling
network
that integrates different stresses hence
the name
but joking aside the importance of the
integrated stress response
comes down to the fact that for a cell
to be functional
it needs to have the right amount
correctly folded
correctly assembled correctly localized
and correctly degraded
protein protein is essential for a cell
to function normally
however for a variety of different
reasons and different stresses
controlling the amounts the folding the
assembly the localization
and degradation of proteins can get
perturbed for example
different stresses include nutrient
deprivation
infection by viruses redox imbalances
and defects in proteostasis so all of
these different stresses
activates the integrated stress response
and the key
output of the stress response is to
inhibit
general translation and effectively stop
any more proteins being synthesized
and the rationale behind this is to
enable the cell to mitigate the stress
and restore homeostasis enabling a cell
to go back to normal
for example in the case where the
integrative stress response pathway
is activated by depletion of nutrients
for example amino acids
preventing general translation prevents
the levels of the amino acids
from lowering even further which could
then cause
cellular death and so this is why it's
called the integrated stress response
pathway because
irrespective of the type of stress that
the cell's experiencing
it all funnels down to the same effect
of being able to inhibit
general translation aka inhibits the
general production of proteins within a
cell
so what is the biochemical underpinning
to the integrated stress response
pathway
well there are four kinases proteins
that add
phosphates to different proteins that
can all activate
the integrated stress response pathway
the four kinases are
gcn2 which is stimulated by nutrient
deprivation
a heme regulated inhibitor hri
that's activated when levels of heme are
low in the cell
pkr that senses double-stranded
rna which isn't supposed to be in a cell
and perk
which is actually stimulated by the
unfolded protein response
that's often commonly thought of when
talking about the integrated stress
response
effectively the unfolded protein
response comes
underneath the umbrella term which is
the integrated stress response pathway
anyway all kinases phosphorylate
proteins
and one protein that all of these
kinases share in common
is e if2 that stands for the eukaryotic
initiation factor 2. and it's given that
name because it's involved in the
initiation of
translation when a protein is generated
from an mrna sequence and how eif2 is
involved in the initiation
of translation is due to the fact that
it carries the first amino acids
of the protein chain now this is where
it starts to get a bit challenging to
understand
but it's also the most important bit to
understand
if you want to understand how is rib is
working
now i said understand the laws in that
sentence but it's a
good word anyway to recap what i've just
said
we know that there's this protein called
eif2
that carries the first amino acid for
protein production
and this protein can get phosphorylated
by these four different kinases so when
it's not phosphorylated
eif2 carries this first amino acid
and also carries a molecule known as gtp
once it's delivered that first amino
acid and adds it to the start of the
protein chain
that gtp gets converted to gdp
after this happens eif2 needs to be
recycled
so that it can begin this process again
but going back to gdp
to gtp requires the help of another
protein
known as eif2b so
a simpler way of thinking about it is
considering that aif2 can be found in
two different complexes
a before and and after and
eif2b helps eif2 go from the after state
back to the before state i hope my
diagrams are doing a better explanation
than myself
but effectively this recycling of eif2
enables the continual production of
different proteins
so what happens when eif2 gets
phosphorylated
well as i've already explained when it
gets phosphorylated
it results in a general inhibition of
translation
and this is because it reduces the
amount of eif2
that's found in the before state i see
how this actually happens
is that the recycling mechanism gets
perturbed when eif2 is phosphorylated
to give my kind of nerdy biochemical
explanation as to why this happens
the addition of phosphate to eif2
creates a strong interaction with
eif2b such that eif2b
interacts with eif2 in the wrong
confirmation
to enable the recycling process so
effectively it sequesters eif2b
and prevents it from recycling aaf2
back to the before states so if none of
that made sense
the key thing to take away is that
phosphorylation
by these different kinases that are
activated by stress
prevents the recycling of aif2 to the
before state that's needed for protein
synthesis
so phosphorylation of eaf2 you have a
general
decrease in protein synthesis now the
reason i went into so much detail here
is that it now brings us onto
is rib the integrated stress response
inhibitor
that as suggested by its name inhibits
the
integrated stress response pathway and
the way that
is rib inhibits this pathway is by
binding to
eif2b and activating it
and as you can see in this video here is
rib is effectively
acting as a so-called molecular staple
that pins together different
sub-complexes of
eif2b enabling it to act
in the recycling process of eif2 to
increase the levels
of the before complex so by inhibiting
the integrative stress response pathway
it prevents that decrease in protein
synthesis
now the two major questions that will
come to mind is firstly
why would you want to do this i just
told you that
this integrative stress response pathway
is an adaptive
evolutionary selected pathway that
enables cells to deal with different
stresses
why would you want to inhibit it and
secondly what has ezrib got to do with
memory enhancement
well let's address the first question
first
why would you want to inhibit the
integrated stress response pathway
well being activated by stress the
integrated stress response pathway
kind of becomes hyperactive or
chronically active during aging and
contributes to age-related brain
phenotypes
for example in the postmortem brains
from individuals
or animal models of alzheimer's disease
parkinson's disease and hunting tones
show an increase in the levels of the
phosphorylated form
of eif2 showing that the integrative
stress response pathway is being
activated
now one explanation for this is due to
the fact that loss of proteostasis is
one of the hallmarks of aging
and this can activate the integrated
stress response pathway
indeed neurodegenerative diseases such
as
alzheimer's disease are characterized by
the presence of protein aggregates
supporting this link between loss of
proteostasis
disease and activation of the
integrative stress response pathway
now associated with aging and these
age-related
neurodegenerative diseases is the
decline in memory
and cognitive performance however
exactly why this happens
still isn't completely understood and so
now feels like a good time to introduce
you to peter walker
a biochemist who did a lot of great work
to understand the unfolded protein
response pathway which is one of the
components of the integrator stress
response pathway
and it was within his lab where they
discovered the compound is rib
and so peter walter had a colleague
nahum sonenberg
and he had data linking eif2
to memory function in mice and so the
two of them together decided to see what
effect
is rib would have on the brains of mice
and what they found was when they
injected its rib
to mice they were three times faster
than normal mice
at locating a submerged platform and so
this is just a test that they can do
with mice
to assess their cognitive ability and
the rationale they had behind this
also comes from the fact that memory
formation depends on protein synthesis
and this has been shown in studies from
invertebrates serious mammals
and so it could be that in aging and
neurodegenerative diseases
while you've got this chronic activation
of the integrated stress response
pathway
the reason that you see memory decline
could be because of the
phosphorylation of eif2 reducing protein
synthesis
that's essential for memory formation
and so this
would be a bit of a paradigm shift in
the idea that
long-term memory deficits may primarily
result
as a consequence of the integrative
stress response activation
rather than the particular proteostasis
defects
that lead to the induction of the
different neurodegenerative diseases
now i'm not entirely sure if that made
any sense so let's now take a look at
some of the data behind this recent
e-life paper
a small molecule cognitive enhancer
refers age-related memory decline in
mice
now no guess is needed as to what small
molecule that's going to be
and so in comparison to previous work
with israel where they looked at the
impact of his rib of alleviating
symptoms after traumatic brain injury
in this study they specifically were
looking at whether or not
this rib could be a potential strategy
for modifying
age-induced neuronal immune and
cognitive dysfunction
and so the way that they did this was
they took old mice so around the age of
19 months
and they gave them is-rib for three
consecutive days
as a concentration of 2.5 milligrams per
kilogram
and they timed this with the learning
phase of a so-called
radial arm water maize and so this is
effectively training the mice to escape
from a watery maze
by finding a hidden platform and
generally this is harder for older
animals to learn
but a week after the older male mice
were given its rib
they were able to accomplish the task as
well as the youthful mice
as can be seen in this figure here and
so you can see in this figure that
the young mice and the old mice treated
with israel
had less errors when performing the task
and so so far
the data does seem to suggest that even
a brief treatment of this rib could
rescue the age-induced
spatial learning and memory deficits
that are commonly seen
suggesting a role of the integrated
stress response on long-term memory
dysfunction
corroborating with this it's rib also
seemed to
be able to reduce dendritic spine loss
and so
dendritic spine loss is commonly
characterized in older mice
and correlates with diminished cognitive
output
and so you can see in this figure here
that there does seem to be an increase
in the number of spines and so whilst
i'm not going to cover all of the data
in this paper
overall there does seem to be some
evidence supporting the use of isrib
in alleviating age-induced memory
deficits
and this effect occurred even with brief
administration
of israel to the mice so is israel a
good
drug well obviously this is very early
data and it's animised not in humans and
so
obviously a lot more work needs to be
done but there are some good
characteristics of
israel that does make it promising for
example it can pass the blood-brain
barrier which is why we can see the
changes in the brain
and it doesn't appear to be toxic to the
mice but we'll come back to that in a
little bit
and so clearly calico think that israel
is promising
which is a company founded by google as
they paid to get the license for the
molecule
but i want to come back to the question
that i asked earlier
the integrated stress response is an
adaptive process within ourselves to
deal with stress
surely inhibiting it would be bad and so
this is potentially the clever part with
israel
as i mentioned earlier its rib binds to
and activates eif2b
but when the integrated stress response
pathway is activated
so when aif2 is phosphorylated it
sequesters eifdb
so if aif2 is sequestering aif2b
it doesn't matter if israel is there it
won't be able to bind eaf2b because it's
already
being bound by eif2 so hopefully this is
a bit clearer in this
graph where you can see that as the eif2
phosphorylation increases
you see activation of the stress
response and
the impact of adding is rib kind of just
delays
the onset of the integrated stress
response
basically meaning that when there's a
strong induction
of the integrated stress response and so
when there's a really high
level of the phosphorylated form of eaf2
israel doesn't really do anything
because it can't because
all of the afgb has been sequestered and
so potentially the reason why
israel isn't toxic is because it
selectively targets cells that have this
kind of chronic
lower level activation of the integrated
stress response
as opposed to more healthy cells that
have a really strong induction
of the stress response but again this is
still really early data and
it's not certain if this would ever
transfer to humans
but it's not just neurodegenerative
diseases and memory deficits that israel
could have potential for
activation of the integrated stress
response is also seen in diabetes
and thought to play a key role in
metabolic disorders moreover
is rib could have potential in cancer
therapy where
cancerous cells increase protein
synthesis which overwhelms proteostasis
activating the integrated stress
response and so
is rib treatment could be a way of
selectively targeting cancer cells
and so even though israel was first
identified back in this 2013 study
it does seem like there's quite a way to
go before we see human applications of
his rib
whether it's used to alleviate symptoms
of neurodegeneration
metabolic disorders cancer therapy or
the aging process
itself and another interesting area
would be to see how
is rib combines with the mtor inhibitor
rapamycin
so mtor is the other major pathway that
responds to environmental stresses and
can
impact protein synthesis and so with
high
enteractivity being shown to actually
activate the integrated stress response
so maybe the combination of rapid mycin
and this rib could be beneficial
but who knows this is early days and
there's a lot of interesting work that
we should be seeing in the next few
years with these compounds and say yeah
um i don't think i have much more to say
well other than the fact that the
integrators stress response is pretty
cool
and i barely went into any detail
compared to what we already do know
about it
but there is so much more we still want
to learn about
the stress response pathway it's just
very cool
anyway i hope you have managed to learn
something from this video and
as always thanks for listening